do you remember
it was about a month or two ago
rand paul grilled dr fauci specifically
over whether or not dr fauci had funded
or supported in any way
gain of function research
period but specifically in the wuhan
institute of virology where the
coronavirus sprang from
gain of function research is where you
take naturally occurring viruses and
beef them up
make them deadlier make them more
transmissible
dr fauci says
absolutely
not
dr falchi do you still support funding
of the nih funding of the lab in wuhan
senator paul with all due respect you
are entitled entirely
and completely incorrect
that the nih has not ever and does not
now
fund
gain of function research
in the wuhan
dr barrett does not doing gain to
function research and if it is it's
according to the guidelines and it is
being conducted in north carolina i
don't think it's concerning a bat virus
spike protein that he got from the wuhan
institute into the sars viruses gain of
function that is not a minority because
at least 200 scientists have signed a
statement from the cambridge working
group saying that it is gain of function
well it is not and if you look at the
grant and you look at the progress
reports
it is not
gain a function now you could tell that
she's real nervous here you could you
could hear it because he messes up his
grammar he said
it is does not and it if it and he also
has an error in logic here where he says
we are not funding gain of function
research
and all the gain of function research
with funding is totally fine
you say hold on which is it
you're not
you're not funding it or well if you
know look and maybe look we're not doing
it but even if we were it'd be north
carolina
well there's a new report out from the
intercept
that says
that that basically nothing in fouchy's
statement was true
he lied through his teeth they funded
gain of function research they funded it
at the wuhan institute of virology
i love blue blocks
not only because they make me look like
rachel maddow but because blue blocks
block the blue light that damages our
eyes and that can lead to digital eye
strain seriously i i no longer
in almost any circumstance will look at
a screen that's got blue light coming
out all the time it's a real problem it
leads to a lot of eye strain blurred
vision headaches dry watery eyes don't
do it this can cause anxiety depression
low energy i know it sounds crazy but
just trust me try out blue blocks they
are evidence-backed they're made under
optics laboratory conditions in
australia
they're created with high quality lenses
for daytime nighttime and color therapy
exactly in line with the suggested
peer-reviewed academic literature
they got over 40 frames so if you don't
want the mat out you can get you get
another one too they come with a
prescription uh go to blueblocks.com
right now use promo code knowles at
checkout get 20 off and enjoy free
shipping on orders over 115 bucks get
your energy back sleep better block out
the unhealthy effects of blue light be
just like me
blue blocks b l u b l o x dot com slash
knowles or click the link below make
sure you use code knowledge to get 20
off your order free shipping on orders
over 115 bucks b-l-u-b-l-o-x dot com
slash knowles for 20 off today
rand paul grills dr fauci puts him on
the spot he says did you fund gain of
function research never no not in the
woohon institute not anywhere maybe
north carolina but really not anywhere
it didn't happen no way no no how
the intercept
just filed a freedom of information act
request
it learned through the documents that
were released that the nih national
institutes of health issued a bat
coronavirus grant to a group called the
eco health alliance this was for 3.1
million dollars it included 599 000
that the wuhan institute of virology
used in part to identify and alter bat
coronaviruses
that were likely to infect humans
this is really bad for dr fauci in the
words of i mean you don't need to take
my word for it well i'm i'm not an
epidemiologist you know i'm not an
expert but dr richard ebright who is a
molecular biologist at rutgers took a
look at these documents he said quote
the documents make it clear
that assertions by the nih director
francis collins and the niaid director
anthony fauci
that the nih did not support game
function research or potential pandemic
pathogen enhancement at the wuhan
institute of virology
are
untruthful
that was a very
diplomatic
way of saying
fauci lied
he lied about his role
in
starting the coronavirus
epidemic potentially
he lied about his role and why did he
lie
if
the
gain of function research
going on if identifying the
transmissible bat coronaviruses at the
wuhan institute of virology if that had
nothing to do
with the outbreak of kovid then why
would fauci lie about it
on national television at the u.s
capitol before a committee of the united
states senate
why lie why try to cover it up
seems pretty bad
[Music]
[Music]